let's throw it to Zagreb where Maurice
Ashley is with the Grantchester
spokesman Michael quarter Kooskia over
the humerus one of the most important
people in the grant chest or not just a
spokesman but also a designer one who
brings much of his creativity to
designing the tour
Mike Karthik offski Mike welcome to the
show once again you must be excited to
see this tournament happening here in
Zagreb such a historic moment for chess
as well absolutely because it's ours
second leg of of this year and second
leg also a new place at Zagreb Croatia
and this is the strongest ever
tournament in Croatia
especially when a reigning world
champion participating and yesterday it
was spectacular opening ceremony and
prior to that prime minister met with
three world champions
a legendary Gary Kasparov Vishy Anand
who's playing here as well and reigning
champion Magnus Carlsen incredible and
so much love for chess here in Croatia
it was a buzz yesterday you see all the
fans in there now you think about us in
the United States how we would love it
if that kind of reaction happen in our
home country tell us you've been here
quite a few times and I know Gary of
course is now a citizen and makes here
his home you were talking about the
beautiful coastlines here in Croatian
yeah well actually I played in 1990 in
Pula which is the coast city and it was
beautiful place if you just go cross
from here a couple of hours to the
seaside you will enjoy it it's so
picturesque
it's so beautiful so Croatia is a really
beautiful country and what is more
important loft for chess in this country
is amazing
probably number three after soccer and
basketball incredible and public is very
knowledgeable
it's not like they just love the game
they understand the game they appreciate
the game and today first they expect and
people are sitting and watching and
analyzing game and they just enjoying
how they cannot believe that it's
happening in Zagreb right now well we
know that first of all the day off the
players will be going to the seaside but
to enjoy that some of that coast also
Zagreb was known for the candidates that
was played in in old Yugoslavia when
they played in Serbia and in czar and in
Croatia and also an Athenian those were
bled I thought that was the three places
my Blair this Slovenia part of Slovenia
exactly so about the whole connection
porters is crazy also in Croatia it's
it's fascinating to see yeah sure I'd
mentioned that when he played here the
fans had that kind of mania about them I
was told in fact in in Belgrade which of
course all of this is connected through
history that they would stand up and
cheer after every win even while players
were still playing their games and
somebody would win and they'd say it's
standing applause congrats to the
victory can you imagine I mean that's a
lot I imagine because I remember that
when I played in Serbia one month later
I came back and I met one of the
Yugoslavia masters thank you so
congratulations you did great third I
said how did you know just he said that
it was in the papers incredible the news
is spreading your vision as in Gary's
vision and every one of the grand chests
or as you see this build of course after
this will be Paris and then we'll be
going to st. Louis how you know we did
I'll be John already now it just it
doesn't does it feel does it ever get
old let's put it that way
well it's amazing feeling we're going
from one place to another and kind of
coming back to your past and see that
the love of the games still there
and this year I need to tell you that
we're going to another European Eastern
European capital Bucharest and you will
see that it would be as much love for
chairs over there as well wonderful to
see the tour expanding as we know when
to Africa going to Asia going to these
new places as well keep up the great
work
micro - coughs key on the board of the
grand chest tour part of why all this
magic happens
thank you